make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with the or
part four right or at least continuing
on with with Donnie catches Thor run
hard for his law run is amazing by the
way like it's it's ridiculously good and
it kind of amazes me that he's firing on
all cylinders like this quickly out of a
gate right like usually most riders kind
of build up over the course of like the
first four five six issues you know and
it's kind of like okay some things
you're happening this one just goes like
from zero to 60 from issue number one
all the way until now right like it's
it's super cool but in the last video
that we did we had talked about how Thor
is basically allied himself with
Galactus right the idea that there's
this threat basically called the the
black winter right in the black winters
arrival could lead to the destruction of
everything right presumably it led to
the destruction of a DC Universe right
it looked like we had Green Lantern and
a flash and Superman and so on and it
looked like they were all killed by the
black winter in their native universe
and the black winter seems to have moved
to the current Marvel Universe right now
we don't really know how this compares
in terms of multiverse is right if it's
just bouncing around between multiverse
is only targeting specific universes we
don't really know what's going on here
all we know is that this black winter
really kind of represents the notion of
like death right the void the fact that
things essentially end and so because of
this we really kind of get this cool
scenario in so far that we had Thor
outline himself with Galactus for the
purpose of consuming five particular
worlds and the consumption of these
worlds would basically lead to Galactus
his power being bolstered in such a way
to where you get essentially fight off
the black winter in turn you also saw
the arrival of beta ray bill Thor
getting into a fight with beta ray bill
over the fact that that basically these
worlds were being destroyed and the life
on it was being consumed and killed by
Galactus in its process of taking over
these various worlds and whatnot and so
as a result of that this essentially
leads to the arrival of sip now SIF
really kind of came here in the midst of
the fight between beta ray bill and Thor
and it kind of presents an interesting
question right because the question here
is why like why would she really
intervene between these two characters
now also keep in mind that SIF is
essentially the new Heimdall right she's
really taken the place of her brother
and so far as she sees everything why
she's the one that's tasked with
regarding the Bifrost
the entrance to and from Asgard or at
least the main entrance to and from Asko
there's a lot of back channels there
different things like that but this is
one we really started to kind of get an
indication of why it is she's here and
the reason why is because Thor goes to
launch the attack right goes to throw a
mule near adder she summons the Bifrost
the hammer passes through the Bifrost
and then ends up in Jotunheim
the realm of Loki this is actually a
pretty big moment and the one thing to
bear in mind is when it comes to the
character of Heimdall and assuming that
SIF has essentially taken on the powers
of her brother insofar as what Heimdall
is capable of doing if you go back and
you read the old journey into mystery
comics right so the tales of Asgard
stories by Jack Kirby which were backup
features to the original journey into
mystery comics they gave us like the
whole history of Asgard essentially from
its origin you got all these different
stories right you got all these
different events and you really learned
a lot about the Asgardian mythos one of
the things you learn about Heimdall is
that Heimdall's ability to see isn't
just simply seeing everything going on
right it's not just cosmic awareness in
so far as he's aware of what's going on
in the entirety of all nine realms
including the main Marvel Universe
Heimdall's ability to see includes the
past the present and the future right so
he can see the future now how far that
reaches we don't really know all the
indications seem to be that his ability
to see the future was relative to you
but what was going to affect Asghar but
it's kind of wax and wane for example
you look at CG and you get a different
kind of explanation we can basically see
all time in space and there's no limit
to it right he can just see everything
going on for for infinity until the
collapse of the universe which really
kind of begs the question why did the
entirety of the incursians happen during
2015 secret wars but nonetheless this is
a cool little bit of a revelation
assuming that SIF has that same level of
power then what we see here is
particularly interesting because the
hammer comes crashing down into
Jotunheim in lands in front of Loki and
remember Loki's currently the king of
the frost giants lafi was basically
killed right he's been dead since the
events of war of the realms I believe
and so Loki is the one you know Loki
actually ended up being the one that
killed him Loki took his place and so
what's kind of crazy here is Loki sort
of begins to look at this and say okay
this is intriguing that this hammer is
landed here because the the enchantment
of Odin says that only those individuals
who were worthy can lift the hammer of
Thor now a lot of people might look at
this to say well Loki's a bad guy but
that's an important thing to understand
here the worthiness enchantment does not
apply to good guys and bad guys the
reality is that the enchantment says
whosoever will holds this hammer if they
be worthy shall possess the power of
Thor the result is that essentially if
Loki is worthy here then Loki could
possess mueller-wright he could lift the
hammer of Thor and that's where things
get kind of bonkers because he
essentially reaches down and then picks
it up now the way the Donnie Cates
handles this is
genius because on one side we would look
at this we would say oh my god Loki
lifted the hammer of Thor really on the
other side we would say but like so many
people have done it though and I like
that Donnie case doesn't turn this into
like a great big huge to do instead of
just kind of like this is really
interesting we'll focus on that in like
four issues right I kind of like the way
he does that right I love the way he
does it he just kind of plays it off as
it's a thing this is gonna build it into
something bigger right but there's never
been an instance that I'm aware of when
Loki has ever lifted the hammer of Thor
well I take that back there's never been
an instance where like Loki is the god
of mischief did it after the events of
axis where you had like the inversion
yeah then Loki was able to do it because
Loki was technically a good guy right
but like Loki is the bad guy that we
know has never lifted Thor's him yes he
has but no he hasn't but essentially you
know he basically tells them leave here
right late else if he tells tells beta
ray bill leave here right like we've got
bigger things to focus on here we've got
bigger things to deal with you guys need
a leak right we're fighting on behalf of
the saving of the entirety of the
universe right like yes a few billion
people are gonna die you know however
many billions you know 50 60 70 billion
people across these five worlds are
gonna die you know it sucks for them but
like how many trillions and countless
other individuals across the universe
are going to survive like classic
utilitarianism the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few and it
doesn't matter how fair it may or may
not be so as a result to that one of the
things is or basically takes a portion
of Galactus as cosmic power and then in
turn helps Galactus travel from world to
world to essentially consume them right
and so the first world is is Silas to
these kind of super small beans who were
there their world is consumed then comes
IO x4
after that you know you literally have
this world after world after world but
each and every one of these worlds were
essentially consumed these remaining
three are destroyed followed by the last
one called
called cry out and this is kind of
interesting here right because when
Galactus in Thor show up on this world
Thor doesn't really go in so far is like
your world's gonna be destroyed now uh
sorry about your luck but like you know
we gotta save the universe
so please it's not really like that
right like he does what the Silver
Surfer would do in that situation if
Galactus were really hell-bent on
consuming a world that has life then the
Silver Surfer would say okay then fine
give me a chance to evacuate the people
on it right Reed Richards did that
during Hickman's Fantastic Four Galactus
one to go consumer particular world the
world was inhabited by sentient beings
and the response of Reed Richards was
well then give me time to evacuate the
people off this world and Galactus is
like you have until my machine is
finished and after that I'm going to
consume the world who
left dies you know and so it's like okay
come on guys let's hurry yeah but it's
basically him showing up you know Thor's
showing up your instinct you know I come
here as a as an agent of peace I come
here to tell you yeah you're world's
gonna be destroyed it's gonna be
consumed yes it sucks but I can help you
get off this world and survive right so
Thor's not really heartless it's not
like he doesn't really care about who's
on these worlds but the universe is more
important than everything right it's
kind of like get them off of if you can
you'll save them if you can but the
response of the people of cryo is no
we're gonna stay here we're not
assembling in the army he's like we're
gonna aid you in our fight right so
they're essentially willing to sacrifice
themselves you know in terms of
everything going on which is kind of
cool right the problem with this is that
initially where they did have the
ability and it really kind of seems they
would have the ability to sort of muster
their armies together and you know
insofar as he says like you know our
armies are not assembled against you the
idea kind of seems to be we can assemble
our armies to help you fight off the
black winter the reality is that
galactus kind of looks at this and
really doesn't really say much about it
doesn't really acknowledge the statement
of these people on cryo and it's kind of
like the world has to go right so
immediately starts consuming it without
giving any real regard for the
individuals on it and initially you
would say okay so maybe it's just kind
of Galactus being tired of waiting the
response of Galactus is one I don't need
your permission to consume a world into
we're out of time the black winter is
here blue the black winter is permeating
across this part of the cosmos and is
now arrived at this planet and people
are really beginning to freak out right
because the black winter again it kind
of dissolves that breaks things down the
various inhabitants of this world
essentially die now one of the things to
also remember as the black winter shows
you what your death is going to be and
Thor takes the smart approach by
blindfolding himself right he can use
his senses and as new cosmic powers to
really see Lia without the traditional
sense right to kind of reach out and
feel the universe around him in the same
way that the Star Wars universe uses the
force as a plot device right like is
that that same thing but nonetheless the
black winters here of course the black
winter basically starts moving towards
that world the whole thing is consumed
quite readily Thor even really kind of
shows a lot of emotion over the fact
that one he might die and to all these
innocent people were basically consumed
right they were basically destroyed and
so the black winter finally really makes
its full-on appearance here shows us you
know in some capacity what it truly
looks like and one it is colossal in
size this thing
dwarfs Galactus right it makes Galactus
look like a regular-sized human being
it's enormous
into it
almost kind of looks like this sort of
you know skeletons version of like
Brainiac from DC right you got like the
sensor in the middle and like the two
eyes I'm pretty sure it's not Brainiac
but it looks like something akin to that
it's a pretty cool looking concept and
if I'm being honest with the eyes I
still think it's the dweller in darkness
right like I still feel like this is the
dweller in darkness who's trying to
destroy or consume the entirety of the
multiverse right like I don't know
that's true or not but that's what
basically led to the death of the of the
multiverse before the current one right
like the one that Galactus originally
came from it was a dweller in darkness
when he fractured the m'kraan crystal
right so like if you go and you read
Adventures of the x-men the miniseries I
think was from the 90s maybe the early
2000s with issue number 12 I think is
the one that covers that I still say
it's a dweller in darkness but
regardless it's cool and I love what
Donnie Cates is doing but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys with
a sub button to become part of the rob4
if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later
Bruce I want to say thank you to all of
the new patrons who have joined
patreon.com slash comics explain I want
to give a shout out to Henry young -
Elias G David J s Jacob H Ben John H
Jason see Austin s Austin H James O
kristymatt in Jeff are Joey M Steven Z
sloth-like Lou David see John H lean and
mean that guy asked questions all the
time Adam Cajun gnosis 9/16 I want to
say thank you to all of you all this
list is growing all the time so you're
joining the patreon
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]